[Ashlee] We're in a car train.
It's going up the Swiss Alps.
There's no one at the wheel.
Oh, there he is.
It's a little scary in here now.
Come on, guy.
I've got a helicopter to catch.
- Travel to Switzerland,
and an obvious thought will hit you.
The country can feel too perfect.
The cities.
The watches.
The cities with watches.
The lakes.
The mountains.
Roger Federer,
the ideal man.
It's all so well made, either
by humans or by nature,
it's almost boring.
And it's true that there
is a museum-like quality
to Switzerland.
It feels like they figured everything out
then stopped.
But let me offer an alternative view.
Because in Switzerland,
you can also find the shock
of the new and unexpected.
The country aims a large portion
of its considerable wealth
at universities and research institutions.
These places are doing fantastic work
in fields like robotics, AI, and medicine.
And Switzerland is also a
country that welcomes immigrants,
at least crazy, smart immigrants
and helps them create
startups from their research.
Let's go meet one.
- Wow.
They are everywhere.
- [Ashlee] Like if I did hit one,
would it just try to get back?
- You mean, like this?
- Yeah.
- And it just finds its location again.
- Yeah, exactly.
- The worst thing that could happen
is that somehow the
propeller hits your eyeball.
- Yeah.
Why did you say that?
- [Ashlee] On this show,
we tend to feature people
who are exceptional.
But the man behind these drones
is unusual even among the exceptional.
- My name is Raffaello D'Andrea,
everybody calls me Raff.
I'm a professor at ETH Zurich
and I'm also the CEO
and founder of Verity.
- [Ashlee] Raff is part math genius,
part robotics pioneer,
and part artist.
- Oh yeah, you can actually
give it a good shove.
- Yep, it balances.
- That's amazing.
- And not only can it balance,
it can actually rotate and
balance at the same time.
- [Ashlee] No way.
- It's very delicate what it does, so.
- I'm scared to move.
The cube was cool,
then he supersized it.
- [Raff] So this is the balancing cube.
- And the goal here is for this to stay
upright and balanced.
- Exactly.
It changes its position.
So it changes the center of mass.
- Yeah.
- To compensate for movement.
- So inside I'm seeing like
motors and circuit boards
- There's motors, there's sensors.
And actually what you don't see,
is that these are all
communicating to each other.
- Raff's talent for engineering
has made him a very wealthy man.
In 2003, he co-founded Kiva Systems
a robotics company specializing
in warehouse automation.
In 2012, Amazon acquired
Kiva for almost $800 million.
For someone who's into
so many things as you,
it must have changed your life
to have Amazon buy the company
and then you get to chase
whatever you want really.
- Yeah, I think I've been fortunate
that I've been able to
do what I want to do.
This is how we tested the first versions.
Yeah, that's me right there.
- [Ashlee] Okay.
Raff discovered his passion early in life.
He was born in Italy,
then moved to Canada at 10
and quickly developed into
a budding mad scientist.
- I did some stupid things.
I learned about pressure
by jumping into a swimming
pool with a hose in my mouth.
I jumped off the roof of my house
with an umbrella, a lawn umbrella,
because I wanted it to
be like a parachute.
- Did you break anything on that one?
- No, I didn't, it was a, you know,
a Canada bungalow, only 10 feet.
- Yeah.
- But what a great way to learn something
by actually putting
yourself in the experiment.
- He miraculously survived to adulthood,
worked and taught in the United States,
and then for good reason,
settled in Zurich.
I've heard Zurich is known as Drone Valley
or something like that, or is that right?
- Yeah, there is a lot of activity
in autonomous systems in general.
Switzerland is known
for doing a lot of cool stuff with drones.
When we started doing
drone research in 2008,
that was still kind of
early days for drones
and there we really aimed
at pushing the boundary
of autonomous flight.
So we did a lot of crazy stuff
with pole balancing and playing ping pong
and a whole bunch of other fun things.
It was a way to motivate the researchers.
If we can make something
that makes people go,
wow that's amazing, then we
know we've pushed the boundary.
- [Ashlee] To commercialize
his acrobatic drones,
Raff started a new company
called Verity in 2014.
They made their artsy machines,
and then oddly, began chasing that sweet,
sweet warehouse management money as well,
hoping to replace fallible humans
with a fully automated system.
- People hate doing inventory control.
It is a detested task.
As a result, people don't do inventory
nearly as often as they should,
and they live with these errors.
In a warehouse that has, you know,
a $100 million of throughput
and there's a 3% or 4%
error in that warehouse,
that's a significant amount.
- Sure.
To help fix some of the costly mistakes,
Verity can send over some of its drones
to work the night shift.
- The drones fly when
there's no one there.
And then the system synchronizes
with the warehouse management
system and then creates a list
of all the things that need to be fixed.
- [Ashlee] Raff showed me the
aerial auditors in action.
- [Raff] It's doing these
very fine adjustments
to make sure that it's in the right spot
of where it needs to be to take the image.
- [Ashlee] Verity's warehouse drones
have been pretty successful,
landing customers like Ikea and Samsung.
They raised a $32 million
funding round in early 2023.
And these drones can do a
lot more than scan QR codes.
- Our entertainment business,
it's less than 10% of what we do,
but it's an important part of what we do.
It's in our DNA, you know,
doing things when
failure is not an option.
- [Ashlee] To Raff, whether
he's flying his flock
past 10,000 boxes of liquid soap
or over the heads of 10,000
spellbound spectators,
very little changes.
- [Raff] You know, for
me, the act of creation
is what I really enjoy.
- Yeah.
- [Raff] And the nice
thing about technology
and specifically robotics and AI,
is that whether it's art,
whether it's industrial practice,
whether it's research,
it's all about taking something
and making it do motion
that hasn't been done
before through mathematics.
This is only 16.
Can you imagine when you have 200 of them?
- Yeah.
I feel like I'm in "A
Midsummer Night's Dream".
- [Raff] It is magical.
You know, we take it for granted
'cause we do it all the
time, but it is amazing
that intelligent monkeys
can do this. Right?
- Yeah.
It could be the case
that crazy, flying robots
don't do it for you.
I understand,
ish.
And so I have prepared for you
something more sci-fi,
more medical,
more epidermis.
Welcome to Cutiss,
purveyors of the finest
lab grown human skin.
Founder Daniela Marino
is another immigrant
turning Swiss R & D into a startup.
She formed Cutiss in
2017 hoping to transform
the way we treat severe skin damage.
If I had a burn in an accident
what would be the standard
thing that happens today?
- So if you today get burned severely,
so you lost quite a substantial
amount of your skin,
you are in danger of life first thing.
So you are admitted in very
specialized burn units.
When your body's ready and out of danger
of risking your life, autografting starts.
Autografting means that
the surgeon takes skin
from somewhere else, not burnt,
on your body, and puts it on the wounds.
If the wounds are very large
it is a clinical challenge
to actually find enough skin.
So what we do is trying
to shift the paradigm
towards saying, okay, give me
a little piece from somewhere,
and I'll take it to the
lab, and I'll make it bigger
and ship it to you back.
We receive a piece of skin of the patient
as small as a stamp
and then we can extract the
stem cells, expand them,
and then recreate skin using
a bioengineering technique.
- [Ashlee] When the skin is done growing,
it looks something like this.
Mmm, delicious.
- Mmm.
- This is both cool and
slightly creepy, isn't it?
- [Daniela] No.
You haven't seen anything creepy
for real in your life then.
- Like how does this look different
to the final product when it's skin?
- The final one is a bit thicker
and it will be much more resistant
because you have all the
cells that keep it together.
- I mean, the one major limiting factor,
it seems right now, is the
pigmentation in the skin.
What's the plan for addressing that?
- So at the moment, we don't
have melanocytes in the culture
which means we are missing the cells
that produce the melanin
and we are now having an add-on therapy
to then simply transfer the melanocytes
from somewhere colored to the white area
and produce the melanin
which will match the color of the patient.
- [Ashlee] So far, Daniela and her team
have treated 50 patients
in clinical trials,
including in one case, a newborn.
- So this is youngest child ever treated
with bio engineered skin.
And you can imagine the
growth of a kid five days old.
- Yeah.
- And now,
two and a half years later.
I mean, the stretch is just humongous
and it's impressive to see the result.
- [Ashlee] If all goes well,
Daniela wants to have
her skin growing machines
set up around the world,
not just limited to
hospitals, but in oil rigs,
commercial kitchens, and war zones.
As ever with biotech,
these things take time and lots of money.
Luckily, Switzerland
adores its science startups
and lavishes them with resources.
- You have a a mixture
of brain force here,
which is incredible.
And next to this innovative hub
you have a very strong startup ecosystem.
So I don't know if I
would've been that successful
creating Cutiss in my homeland,
Italy, or somewhere else
because here you really
are nurtured as a startup.
- Yeah, 'cause there's
not that many countries,
I think, where you could
raise the amount of money
it would take to...
a company that has to have
a few years to get going
because of all the clinical trials and-
- Sure, long term investment, for sure.
- Most places are not willing
to kind of sit through that.
- This is a very, very expensive journey.
And there is no plan B, I
mean, it has to be like that.
So, let's see.
I hope I continue
raising the money I need.
- If she's able to bring
the technology to market,
it could impact millions
upon millions of lives.
I just hope that after my next adventure
I don't require her services.
We're flying straight into the mountains.
It's scary.
Zurich is a lovely town.
But this is Switzerland,
and there are natural wonders to see.
I'm told there's nothing like soaring
around the Alps in a helicopter.
However, dodging crags in a metal cage
is somewhat well, extremely terrifying.
Mostly because I'm not a pilot
and I don't want to start learning
at 13,000 feet.
As it happens, however,
I am that lucky tourist who knows a guy
who can make all of my
sightseeing dreams come true.
- My name is Fabi Riesen.
I have the pleasure to be the
CEO of Loft Dynamics Company.
Basically, Loft is producing
the world's first flight
simulator training device
using virtual reality technology.
- [Ashlee] Okay.
- So it's kind of like a-
- Truthfully, I'm a bit of
a flight simulator veteran.
But even at the high end training centers
pretend flying still has its limitations.
You go to NASA or something
and you expect it to be
space agey and cutting edge.
But the simulators always look
like they were built in like the 1980s.
I mean, it seems like technology
that hasn't changed in a long time.
- Yeah.
Those gigantic domes
give you a very nice view
but the main challenge is
everything outside is projected.
So if you have two
objects behind each other
and you move the head,
you kind of like see
that they are moving against each other.
On the dome projection, nothing happens.
With virtual reality,
this is basically not the case anymore.
And it's like real from
a visual point of view.
- [Ashlee] Fabi built
his first VR simulator
in his living room,
earning himself the title
of greatest dad of all time.
He eventually upgraded to a real workshop.
- [Fabi] Swiss Quality.
- [Ashlee] Does this all get
made in Switzerland here, or?
- Yes. Yeah.
- Yeah. Okay.
The simulators sell for
under a million bucks,
way less than a traditional dome-type sim,
which is good because the world
needs a lot more of these things.
- Let's talk about the
pilot shortage a bit.
I mean, it seems like
there's not enough pilots
and then there's just a ton of training
both for new pilots and older pilots,
right, to keep their skills up.
Is that the general idea?
- Yes, on one hand
it's quite expensive to
use the real aircraft.
- Yeah.
- To do it.
And on the other hand, the
simulators are also expensive
and there are simply
not enough simulators.
So we are continuously
below the actual need from the pilots.
- [Ashlee] The true test
was giving one of these
whirly birds a whirl.
Get to the chopper!
- [Tamara] And we're going to
give you a bit of forward speed.
- This is cool.
- All right, I'll give you the control
in 3, 2, 1.
Your control.
- Do I need to get higher to get?
- Yeah, you need to get higher
because you want to get over that hill.
so keep pulling, keep
pulling, that's good.
- [Ashlee] Oh boy.
Whoa.
- Okay.
- What do I do?
- I'm going to take the controls.
We haven't even started with the pedals.
- [Ashlee] Wait, what do
the pedals actually do?
Ooh.
- [Fabi] You know what?
Let's make him land the aircraft.
- [Ashlee] Whoa.
- Okay. Okay.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa
- [Tamara] You're going to
crash into the building, but.
You're going down really fast.
Okay.
Okay, now you managed to crash.
- As far as I was concerned,
I had officially graduated
Swiss Flight School.
I blame you.
Now it was time to try the real thing.
So Fabi sent me on a four
hour drive into the Alps.
Destination, Zermatt.
A charming mountain town
where we could take off
and cruise the skies together.
We're at Air Zermatt.
The Matterhorn is just over there.
I'm going to meet up with Fabi
and I think he's getting here right now.
You travel in style, huh?
With a little help from ace pilot, Julie.
- Like that, good.
- [Ashlee] It was time to
put my skills to the test.
- [Julie] You want to try
it a little bit of this?
- [Ashlee] All right.
- [Julie] Really, really slowly.
Okay. Your control.
- [Fabi] Ashlee, have you realized
she's not holding anymore, the control?
It's fully your control.
- [Ashlee] Don't tell me that, please.
- [Julie] You're not breathing.
You have to breathe.
Have you seen, you're turning yourself?
- [Ashlee] Did I actually
just do that or did you help?
- [Julie] Oh, no, no, you did it.
- [Ashlee] No way.
All right, I don't like
it when we get so close
to the mountain though,
then I get freaked out.
- No problem, you can
turn again to the left.
I come with you now.
- Okay. Yes, please.
- Because we go just there.
- That was both exciting and
terrifying at the same time.
I actually flew, it was really cool.
- [Ashlee] Before heading home,
Fabi insisted I meet his buddy Mario,
a mysterious mountain man who's invested
in some of the best tech
startups in Switzerland,
including Fabi's.
- [Fabi] Knock, knock.
- [Mario] knock, knock.
- Hey.
- [Mario] Come in.
- [Fabi] Mario, how are you? Doing good?
- Good to see you guys.
- [Ashlee] Hello. How are you?
- Pleasure to see you.
- [Ashlee] Nice to meet you.
- Warm welcome.
Sit down. Beer, gin and
tonic? What do you like?
- [Ashlee] Mario had all the trappings
of an eccentric, free spirit,
right down to his underground,
secret passageway and spa.
- [Mario] Watch your head here.
- [Ashlee] Okay.
- [Mario] First, this is the wellness area
and this is where I have
the wine and spirits.
- [Ashlee] I saw it, yeah.
So that's the Matterhorn
right out the window.
- That's the Matterhorn right there.
And of course I know a lot
of rich people and whatever
and they are impressed by the house,
so they offer me tons
of money for this house.
- Yeah, and what do you tell them?
- I tell them, not on
sale and never on sale.
This here is my house and
that's where my spirit is living
and giving me opportunities
to be creative.
- Mario was born in Zermatt
and has lived many lives.
Restaurateur,
hotelier,
mountain climber,
ski instructor
and eventually tech investor.
Stirring the fondue,
I feel like now I get Swiss citizenship.
If you manage to reach
his fortress of solitude,
he is a gracious host.
- Cheers, and thank you
so much for being here.
- Cheers. So nice meeting you.
Thanks for inviting us into your home.
So kind of you.
- Cheers, Fabi.
- [Ashlee] Appreciate it.
Mario told me about some of the ventures
he has in the works.
- First we make a carbon
fiber out of algae.
- Okay.
- We reinforce this with stone.
- [Ashlee] And then he told
me about them some more.
- This is not rusting. It cannot.
You can imagine what impact is
this having on construction.
- Yeah.
- Also for the ski industry.
My goal is now to build the house
completely CO2 neutral, even negative.
This would be sexy.
Yeah, it has to be sexy.
- So you've been to the
North Pole, the South Pole.
You've climbed the eight
highest peaks, right?
- Yeah, yeah, traversing Everest.
When I'm doing expeditions,
I can calm down
because I think one day I will be crazy.
I'm enough crazy already, but.
- I feel like you calm
down by doing more stuff.
- Yes, but it is running on high speed.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because if-
- [Ashlee] It seemed that Mario
was a kind of spirit animal
of the Swiss tech scene.
- [Mario] And with this I can-
- [Ashlee] Moving at hyper speed,
embracing new ideas
flush with cash and perched
atop a majestic alp.
Bless this country.
But this wasn't the end
of my Swiss journey.
It was time to trade in my
helicopter for a bicycle
and take a mind expanding trip.
Woo hoo!